[Music]
well everyone is getting canceled left
and right everyone is getting accused of
sexual harassment left and right and the
one we're talking about today is Chris
D'Elia this very skill is right now I
didn't follow the whole tired thing but
I seent it here we go that was him
before he's a [ __ ] skeleton right now
like smoking Oh easy stressed out he's
wrecked bro it's crazy how do you know
do you talk to him yeah I was doing I
was just off the phone did he do it well
yeah so he's being accused of sexually
harassing multiple women and so the big
thing about this is the fact that he had
a lot of women came forward with their
own their own stories and like their own
receipts like screenshots of
conversations with Chris and a lot of
them they are very clear with him about
their age so their underage girls and
he's still pursuing them and it's just
it's a very bad look teenagers yeah
and so there's even this one story where
he he was hitting up this girl she was
16 and he was telling her that like oh
if you suck my friend off then no like
you got to meet me it was like I'm
kidding - no it also that's a point
where like this girl was like what the
hell and then the friend hits up the
girl and then the girl obviously never
goes yeah goes and does it you know we
need to set this [ __ ] you'll be in
the living room and I'll be in the
kitchen let me know how it is after it's
done right no well before that before
the friend got into the picture
apparently Chris was like trying to like
vet her or something like try see if she
was worthy of meeting him and then that
he's a job skill you're really 15 are
you gonna be 22 when you show up that's
gonna be a deal-breaker for me and then
when she didn't like his friend off he
got so angry at her and was like no
you're not gonna meet me then what the
[ __ ] it's funny because he played he
plays a pedophile like two differently
so he played a pedophile in the show the
Netflix show you and he actually gets
killed off too so its methods a massive
spoiler method acting but all of these
all of these are also just allegations
right like we don't know if it's true or
not
well the receipts are pretty pretty nuts
yeah Photoshop these days like people
can also like I guess at one problem I
have with this I don't know if he's
guilty or not the one problem I have
with this is we do have a court of law
I don't know if these females already
approached it and this is their cry for
help because the judicial system failed
them so they want to take it to the
public but we do have a court of law and
that's where they get to examine
evidence and you get to present your
case and they get to defend and I don't
know if they're if they're doing that or
if they already try to do that and it's
not working but that part that I feel
bad for not just him this isn't like I
don't have a personal relationship with
them but just anyone that's getting
cancelled out there is that you're not
doing what Americans are supposed to do
so that people can have a right to fight
for their name and then immediately you
already labeled something like now in my
mind I can't help it I see Chris Lee I'm
like pedophile pedophile you know yeah
and he hasn't even been proven I don't
even know I haven't I haven't examined
the evidence I haven't seen the receipts
or anything like that and who knows that
the receipts are even Photoshop I don't
even know but I just don't like the
method that things are getting done no
that's always important remember that
Bart just defended a pedophile oh god
damn it that is a scary thing about to
get cancelled immediately without any
sort of you can't get your word in this
is actually going on in the gaming
industry right now - really dude there's
this past week so many people in the
gaming industry has gotten got cancelled
like streamers they're horny Oh like
just sexual abuse allegations and stuff
like that like struggles are being too
horny it's been pretty bad yeah well you
were talking about receipts and stuff
right so the LA Times spoke to a lot of
these women who accused Chris and a lot
of them they were able to provide
screenshots like including the phone
number that he would text these girls
with and they would be the same number
and then they looked into the number and
it is connect
- Chris so like that's kind of like at
least in terms of le times for them they
found the proof though that's what I
mean that's le times right conducting
the investigation which is already a
conflict of interest because for them
they want to get stories right so it's
like it's it's not the right avenues
even if they if they did an
investigation to hand it over to police
or whatever they can take it over but
they're taking it and then they're
making news out of it benefitting le
times making money first like for this I
don't know if there's enough of a legal
thing there pending
yeah because I heated for a lot of these
stories he didn't actually get physical
with the girls it was just like his like
predatory behavior but like is that
enough to convict I don't know probably
not so then in that case exposes us for
help [ __ ] creepy is and how he's
abusing his power to the media and at
least everyone else can make the poll I
think we can make it legal because it's
harassment it's sexual harassment if
you're talking to a minor sexually
already that's illegal anthony weiner
went to jail for this in new york yeah
so so that could be this this would hold
in court it's difficult for me to judge
a person's character like for okay so
there's one side of me that's going man
I feel horrible for the women and I want
them to be heard and this sucks if this
happened it sucks yeah but also I think
we have due process and that's important
to remember because we as the society
today we don't do due process we just
say [ __ ] this guy cancel this guy he's a
pedophile yes and you're defending a
pedophile right and if you if you do and
if you raise the question of hey can I
check your sources they go what you
don't believe a woman and it's like well
that's not fair
because we have balance it out right and
I think the point that Bart is really
making is that there is no due process
anymore it's just a public lynching
because it's literally a firing squad
because someone's character is not
likeable anymore and if he's guilty in
court fryers ass I'm completely cool
with that he takes whatever he deserves
you know and if the accusations come out
to be false
then the girl she'll have to do
right wait there's a girl that got
caught doing that recently yesterday
actually with the one of the one of the
streamers and their mutual friend came
out she said that this guy raped her and
nothing was ever wanted like she was
staying at his house and he raped her
but her friend who was also both there
our mutual friend came out like no dude
they were in a relationship here's all
the screenshots in a Google file well
she got cancelled I don't know if I
believe that a woman would never lie
about such a thing
that's what Lena Dunham said on Twitter
so that's touched her sister she the one
that wrote girls she raped girl she
wrote curls her eyes she molested her
sister I admitted to it in a book in a
book yeah yeah well your sister and
forcing her to click kiss her for like
candy and give her money to whoa yeah
the counter your point Bart I think with
the the difficulty of due process and
all that is like there's money involved
and there's difficult like processes
that people can't go forth with right
like like for example like they have to
hire lawyers they have to and it's it's
like that extra movement to do that I
think that's what's preventing people
from speaking out against certain things
and some people they feel alone so then
they do things like this and speak out
in order to connect with other women
that might have been a victim of what
Christy D'Elia was like are Kelly's case
right like how many of those women got
silenced or bought out or the families
got or peed on so that to me is part of
the process right if you try the process
the process fails you you choose another
avenue that's what I'm saying but don't
jump the process and I think if you
report if you report a crime you can at
least get a public defender which is
free so I think if you do follow the
steps there are the the system is
created to help protect you and help
protect everyone so that's just what I'm
like I'm also just counter to because I
agree with everything you're saying I
agree with all this but they also have a
right to speak like freedom of speech
they have the right to say what happened
to them and like what they went through
and and he has a right to say here's my
side of the story yeah
you're ultimately trying to prevent
though what it sounds like to me though
at least is you're trying to prevent
people from from putting out a lie and
the public receiving it as a truth and
then you're sticking with that so I
think that's where you're most cuz like
he said you think Chris D'Elia now it's
a pedophile joke immediately like what I
think of him I think pedophile can't
even help it right yeah so like I think
that's what I'm like the the problem
with people just speaking freely another
person speaking freely like I think we
all have our own bias so of course you
see like a female that's underage we're
like we immediately want to protect them
without and then without without even
giving Chris the benefit of the doubt
and that's the scary part because and
now it's easy with in the deport we have
why we have judges is so that they can
really look at bias yeah they can look
at the evidence and hopefully it's
unbiased but right now it's not it's
like the the the entire public is the
jury in it not only the public but it's
also his closest friends too so for
example Whitney Cummings she came out
with her own statement she said it's
taken me a couple days to process the
information I have learned about Chris
I'm devastated and enraged but by what
I've read and learned this is a pattern
of predatory behavior the abuse of power
is enabled by silence now that I'm aware
I won't be silent girls should be able
to be a fan of a comedian they admire
without becoming a sexual target it's
the adults responsibility to be an adult
so just seeing her stance on this kind
of solidifies it for the public as well
because they are very close so the fact
that she's saying this he's on her shell
right yeah that's how he became famous
was by being the boyfriend on her show
and so yeah like just with that alone it
just kind of solidifies you it for you
in your head but he also gave a
statement to TMZ he said he had never
knowingly pursued any underage women and
that all of his relationships had been
both legal and consent he says that
being said I really am truly sorry I was
a dumb guy who absolutely let myself get
caught up in my lifestyle he's like I
wish I was born 100 years ago pedophilia
was that
sounds almost like uh admittance the
guilt you like I let it slip up I got to
horny guys I got way too horny are we
gonna talk about ron jeremy oh you just
got charged or accused - what ain't the
porn story oh yeah so he might be
convicted 290 years in prison because
there's several women coming out and
accusing him of like is 810 years per
inch that's why it's 90 it is but still
like it's just like it's a natural
wonder of the world okay I'm just so
confused like our porn stars calling him
out or like ratting random women I mean
I just read the headline cuz I'm not
sure what we're gonna do when I'm making
this statement it's not because I think
that porn stars can't be raped or
sexually harassed I'm just curious where
they draw the line because the sex
industry is exactly that sexual yeah I
think one of them was at a party then at
a party where she like he forced himself
but actually to me seems like the most
like the hotbed of sexual assualt
because it's so like oh this is all
we're doing right you should be okay
with this I should be able to do this to
you and then like for the person
reciting it I'm thinking
circumstantially right it's not that it
doesn't exist in that industry there's
sex slavery there's all that stuff where
exploitation does happen but I would be
careful to speak about an industry I
don't know what is the cultural mores
and what is the first-line area thing
that is done in that industry actually
okay so I know a couple of them foreign
stars over the years and they're very
very professional so like when you show
up on set like everything tested first
on [ __ ] and then when they're engaging
scene it's very communicative like and
they think makes and [ __ ] like it's not
what you see on camera and then off
camera but even when they're like
choking and they have spit yeah yeah
when they're the girls throwing up in
another girl's butt hole then she's the
girl's butt hole these are break
so yeah that imagery of two girls one
cup I know that uh okay so after they
say cut sometimes girls have been like
molested or accosted in the shower and
stuff oh my gosh afterward that's posts
like the scene by [ __ ] who are
there it's like the game is on well no
it was it's usually like one of the
fellow performers that's about a couple
years ago I think it was that's what
James Dean was accused of a couple years
ago as well I don't know if that's
exactly who but by remember he was
accused for his ex-girlfriend right so
it is very it's very what professional
[ __ ] like and obviously there are cases
were it's not at all and those guys are
usually weeded out of the industry yeah
creeps are creeps are creeps are creeps
man yeah that's why I like with Justin
Bieber recently likes because
everything's going so crazy he's like
hold on let me unload all these receipts
but people are still taking those in
there like this doesn't prove that you
weren't there one hundred thousand
thousand percent at the belt my Biebs is
perfect you got is he getting me to
right now he was for a little bit but I
don't I haven't heard anything like big
well it got to the point where Justin
Bieber said that he will now be look
like talking to his lawyers to pursue
legal action towards this Twitter
account that said that they got sexually
like I think raped or something so now
it's it's gone to the point of
defamation and he's going after that oh
that means terrifying to have a fleet of
lawyers from celebrity coming after you
that's a lot of reasons why they don't
come out yeah he looks crazy about this
stuff too though is that we all form
opinions when I hear things right it's
like when I remember what oh she was
going down and everyone had had a
thought on that like this is almost the
same thing as that but on social media
right we all see Chris D'Elia [ __ ] I I'm
like yo this guy's definitely skis in on
underage girls cuz of all the [ __ ] I've
read about it and then yeah I do think
due process is important but I'm like I
haven't pain about this like that that's
and that's all I think a lot of people
are doing out there I know it's fun to
like be like well the social media
shit's destroying everything but I think
that there is something good in a lot of
this because I think that a lot of these
guys who are skis and on chicks will
think twice mm-hmm and that's tight do
you guys think that to deter false
accusations
you think that having a super harsh
punishment for it would actually work it
also so that's the scary part because
then you know like it also could deter
people that have legitimately not enough
scared that the minute they enter the
because the the judicial system is also
something people gain yeah so they get
in there and then they're like oh [ __ ]
they can turn the whole thing around on
them too and and now they are gonna get
punished when their case sacrilegious is
that scary
stay in our house I think if we can
prove ill intent for example the
football player kid that got his career
ruined because she was accusing him of
rape and the intention was to destroy
his career then I think we can you know
punish that accordingly but a lot of the
times I think that some people might
have a different perspective of what
happened and usually in court I think
that's why the justice system is so
complicated is when you have a civil
trial you just have two different
opinions of what is right and what is
wrong and it's a moral issue based off
of that so what's happening right now is
I think like it's good that people are
talking and and and spreading awareness
because we're figuring it out as a
society what is the new standard of
today
[Music]
you
you